hello
how is this going hope you've had
a good start of your week
um here my school central university
just started yesterday so
that seems to be going
sorry i'm trying to check out the chats
on youtube and i get ads yay all right
so great i'm live finally
we got some viewers thank you for
staying around all right um
so i was checking out some of my old
games
per usual and i wanted to share
some experience that i had playing
against retti
so first move knight f3 i thought it
would be interesting to just take a look
at that because i don't think we've ever
tried a
scene what to do against righty or just
some of the ideas
on how to respond just some different
ideas
alright so i really really want to get
to show you these games i think
both of them are from
20 no this one is 2017 yeah
i thought this was a little more recent
well never mind
so this game i was black against a
grandmaster
and this was in a tournament
called lugano 2017 which i thought was a
i thought i did yes i did win the lugano
2 tournament 2017. that was a
good tournament it was good to win the
full tournament because i keep getting
like the best moment prize the best like
second best one prize
top 10 but this was uh one of the few
opens that i actually won
she was pretty nice all right um so
let me show you this um game that
happened all right so knight f3
i know a lot of players starts with
knight f6 some players try with d5
a lot of player plays c5 so there are
different things that you can try
but um right now my favorite is a still
knight f6
and after g3 i like b6 i also like b5
i think i've shown a game from b5 i also
intend to show b5
next week a little bit more about it's
not necessarily just against g3
but um ideas that include b5 as black
so reverse g4 right
all right so um after g3 b6
bishop g2 you have to get a bishop out
and um you kind of have two choices you
can try to get your bishop out from
fiance
or you can try to get it out um
the other way well there are other
options too you can try to
i mean i feel like if you wanted to play
this knight f6
g6 you could probably would have done it
earlier maybe just
here you can just go for g6 so you don't
really need to have this
b6 out in order to play east g6 but
anyways um i'm a ninja indian player i
really wanted to continue down before
new zealand came so i just went for e6
got the visual about as you can see my
opponent
is a big fan of doing um
the bishop's fiance style right
all right um so i kind of want to take a
second
and ask the chat what do you guys think
is the next few move for black so how do
you think we're gonna fight for the
center
most likely it's gonna be short castle
so what do you guys think
heidi how are you gonna fight toward the
center are you gonna do c5 or d5 now
oh hello from colombia nice i have
friends in colombia
i think d5 is interesting but i think d5
is i think
still kind of soon yeah so i think we
are between three moves basically c5 d5
or short castle
so i think it kind of depends on
how you want to play it i want to try my
best and be as tricky as possible
so i just went with c5 and
then i just castle i'm waiting to see
what my opponent is gonna do if opponent
plays d4
then i kind of i mean i can choose to
take or i can choose to play d5
but if we play the d5 early on then
if you're kind of giving opponent a
chance to want to like take and
potentially play d4
and now my bishop is kind of defensive
so that's kind of why i wanted to
just try and see what the opponent does
all right so finally d5 take take d4 we
get into the position that we were just
talking about
but at least we're a little bit more
prepared right
so another question in these type of
positions
what do you want to do with this knight
so how basically how do you want to
develop
because um i've played different
versions
of this openings
like i hadn't i had i've had few games
that
i played um like i got to similar
position like this
some of them were with v3 some of them
were with like a bishop was out
on f4 and or g5 and with e3
so i kind of just want to
get your opinion on how do you want to
develop
oh we got someone from england my
brother lives in england
yeah i think knight c6 is um good
some people prefer knight d7 and they
try to like do
this style but i haven't ran into
too many problems playing nice c6 the
only thing with knight c6
is that if take um well i mean you're
kind of
gonna take with the pawn anyways so you
would be dealing with
the um kind of like
it's not as stable pawn structure as you
would like
but at the same time these are mobile
so it's also quite dangerous for
opponents
but also it's weaker for you opponents
can attack it
so yeah exactly uh kind of
interesting type of hanging pawns
because technically
i mean you're not hanging the pawn just
yet but yeah so you just have to be
careful on
how you are placing them these pawns
all right so my partner foreign c1 which
i believe
it was the best move especially because
after c1 you're just kind of
waiting and putting pressure on your
opponent's pieces
oh trying to get the knight to c5 would
have been interesting
so let's just go back a second something
like knight a6
i'm not the biggest fan of knight to
asics just because well
if you're doing nice a6 to get it to e6
then sure
i like it but um knight is 6 by itself
for the idea of getting it to c5 well
you're not you're not i mean he can just
play e3 oops you can just play e3
you're not gonna take that to get the
knight to c5 are you
because then the knight takes and this
is a huge issue
so i think knight getting to c5 isn't
as interesting of an idea but if the
knight could be on e6
i completely like that all right
so on knight c6 finally we got this
knight e4
we talked about knight t4 a little bit
before but we talked about it with
knight d7 knight f6 but i think knight
e4
is kind of just the best way that
black can try to take control of the
center
um actually i might have
said this wrong my opponent was higher
rated than me
but he was not a grandmaster believe he
was just an international master
oops my bad but still he was my rated so
i'll take the pride of winning this game
all right anyways
uh my point was that i was planning
someone who
wasn't that much stronger than me just
he had high rated but
um we we were i mean
i didn't get out of the position i
didn't get out of the opening um
having a bad position i have a pretty
decent position having started with
black
so my idea was that i kind of just
wanted to
do my best to push as much as i can and
provide some chances for my opponent to
make mistakes
which i ended up achieving but
anyways so after knight e4 if um
well if white makes the mistake of
taking this knight
then we are gonna attack this pawn right
so even
if knight goes to d2 we can go here this
pawn is still under attack
if you were to play something like
knight maybe e5 then i can just pick
this up and my bishop is defending my
pawn
so this would already be better for
black right so
um no i wasn't trying to necessarily
talk about how much the rating matters
whereas um sometimes i mean if you are
the i try my best not to
uh be influenced by my opponent's
strengths
but at the same time if it's someone
that is
um like much lower rated then i might
choose some differently to so that's
some
one of the things that i've talked about
in arches and psychology courses
previously as well we talked about
something like okay uh
when you take something like if i was
going to take something in the center or
take on c3
it would have been a little bit
different different because if there are
um like only moves on the board
then it might be harder for someone who
is much lower rated to find them
compared to someone who's like higher
rated so just
just something like um just kind of like
what to expect from the opponent so i
can predict what my opponent is going to
do
more efficiently anyways so uh actually
e3 here is also interesting just to keep
d4 defended
and you see the thing is if i were to
take something like
if i were to take on d4 then the e would
take back
and i mean i still like the
black at the position black has the
knight on e4
um the bishop is kind of blinded so as
long as i get this bishop
out then i think i mean i kind of like
this position
let's see why not um what else can we
think about
if not take bishop a6 is also
interesting
forcing your key one
then maybe i can try to go jump around a
little bit
but anyways i don't think this is
actually going to work
but it's just interesting to look at so
i think
e3 would have been a move to definitely
consider because
e3 would have like given me chances to
want to make mistake and i think that's
something i should have
tried instead of just take because after
take
and now i basically have um
two choices either i gotta take this
knight
and um then take the pawn or if i take
the pawn i'd lose this d5 pawn so
that's not a choice right i mean it's
not a very
smart choice another idea that we could
have tried is bishop f6
because now i'm pinning this knight see
so you can't really take on d5 you're
gonna lose this
you could take on e4 but after
take over there if you move your rook
then i can just
you know take here it's like this oops
not that way this way
so um as you can see this would have
caused some serious issues for white
but bishop f6 is interesting but it's
still not the most accurate
because white can simply play
knight back to d2 now this night is
defended
and it's uh i would have to take this
with the night and
as you can see it's um not
that pleasant right so
it's still doable there's not it's not
like i
couldn't play this but um it's not the
most comfortable for black
this would be the most comfortable for
black and this is what i did
so now i have this d4 coming up
potentially
trying to get the queen to the queen
side maybe did rook on d8
now the position is kind of um getting a
nice flow
so he blinds queen d3 i assume queen d3
was to just develop get an idea on my
king side because my king side is
lacking this knight right
maybe you want to bring up the rook i
think when d3 was a smart choice
d4 gotta go back i'm not entirely sure
about bishop a1 because
the bishop here is not going to be doing
much
because of this pawn on d4 it's kind of
blinding you right
so maybe would have been more
interesting to play bishop d2
and then just try to do something in the
king side
i'm not saying that bishop d2 is like
dangerous and i would have started to
like try to defend some stuff but bishop
d2 makes more sense to me than bishop
db2 i i think maybe bishop a1 was
having some ideas with e3 but
at least bishop d2 should have been um
considered yeah i agree this should be
two bishop f4 i think that's um
one of those ideas that is definitely
interesting
all right so um
after bishop a1 i'm going to take a
second and ask you guys what do you want
to do
so black to move how do you want to use
this
the space that you gained
because if you give white moves but it's
gonna start playing
some rook d1 some e3 and what's gonna
just
take care of your um spatial advantage
yeah i do like to knight b4 idea
anything else
um ether is not bad for black the only
thing is that e3 gives white
more room to greet and we don't like
hopeful opponents we don't like
opponents having um chances to
kind of mess with my center so that's
why we're hoping that
we will eliminate this e3 ideas
um so yes i do like knight b4 i
i don't like queen c7 just because this
is already
giving me a little bit of a boy style
because um
i mean there isn't i i don't see a
threat right away but you're not also
not really stopping e3
so um i think a5 is interesting but
i assume you have the bishop a6 idea but
i think
coin b6 is better than a5 so
honestly i'm between knight b4 or queen
b6
between which two to choose i think
they're both just
good but maybe queen b6 a little bit
more interesting
just because i didn't do it in the game
i think that's why i feel like it's more
interesting
um
yeah yeah good good very well said why
not queen c7
all right yeah i think queen v6 is um
definitely worth considering but anyways
i went with knight before
i wanted to play aggressively after
queen b1
now what do you guys want to do because
the queen on b1 is still
i mean queen b1 was pretty much the only
one you could try queen d2 as well to
defend a2
but i think when b1 was the best one
defending a2
staying out of the works ways maybe want
to start doing stuff like this
so black to move how do you want to
follow after knight b4
yep thank you queen a5 seems quite
interesting right
queen a5 is great um you could try
something like f5
2 but i i wasn't ready for
um f5 and i know i just said i wanted to
play aggressively
but i feel like queen queen kind of
belongs in the queen side so let's let's
let's play this queen beast
queen a5 and make some
issues over there and we'll see how it
goes
so now white to move what do you think
it's white's best move
because if white doesn't do
anything well it's just going to lose
this a2 and then that the game is
becoming quite easy for us
so why to move what do you think white
should do in this position
keep in mind to take a look at
[Music]
the how to make candidate moves we've
talked about this quite a lot
well a4 is definitely a candidate move
but at the same time a4
is uh weakening b3 so we're gonna play
with b8 we're gonna start doing
stuff on that but hold on
before we start thinking about a4 we got
to take a look at all of our candidates
so a4 yes i think a4 is a candid move a3
is also candidate move because
if a3 there are some issues with taking
oh i'm still not seeing anybody say this
move
um so
let's see how else can i
give some tips without giving up the
move
maybe i look for defenseless pieces in
the position so
in black position which pieces are
defenseless pretty much the two bishops
right they're not really being defended
by anything
so can you try and use something like
that oh thank you
exactly knight d4 would have been the
best move for right
i kind of have to take over there knight
f5
i can't really take on i mean i i
probably have to take on f
one but i was thinking maybe bishop g5
to attack this guy
but i can't really do that because
simply king takes take
take and now g7 is
a huge issue but f6 just
knight's going to go to e7 maybe
then you got to bring up the king and
this is going to be
a quite painful game how about
bishop please f1 can we play it can you
not play it
well white's gonna definitely take here
and then why it's gonna take that
what sorry what's gonna take that
if white takes that what do you think
about this do you like this position
do you think this is that's for black
would you want to pack this position as
black
pretty much whatever answer you give
you also better think about something
like rook c4 because now h7 is a huge
issue right
you can't really stop that exactly
exactly queen of seven ideas are coming
up
so it's kind of hard to try and stop
those ideas
i mean you can't try with maybe h6 but
there's a rookish four
and queen on b1 defending and attacking
everything so
yes um if white were to make mistake and
take on
f1 then yes i think would correct uh
play
then why black could get away with this
i mean black would definitely
save the king and enjoy the more
material
that black is black has right now but
um if you're c4 then actually
white is much better
almost winning like you have to play f5
and this is already
kind of like oh boy all right
so in this position that's why we could
think about bishop g5 but that's
still uncomfortable i wouldn't really
want to
be an exchange up in this position
it just it's really hard to try
and save this position
alright so knight to d4
would have been the best move for white
would have created
a lot of problems for us as black and
it's not like after knight takes d4
you i mean you can't take it but then
the bishop takes on
b7 and this guy is also weak
he's probably just gonna go to e4 attack
over here attack that
yeah i don't really like this position
honestly
all right so 94 would have been the best
move my opponents didn't do that
he just played with a3 a4 was another
idea that was mentioned
but now we can simply just play rick um
v8 stop all of these knight d4s
because now this guy is defended right
now you can just go with rook e8 that
serves the same purpose
no more knight f5s because this is
definitive
right uh a4 is weak yes a4 would make
white's position weaker because now b3
is an issue
why didn't my opponent take on d4 was it
just afraid well the same reason nobody
in the chat mentioned
d4 when i asked well there was
one person who did mention it but after
i mean nobody saw it just looking at it
and i'm pretty sure he didn't see it
because i mean if he saw it
i think he would have done it because
there is nothing stopping it when you
see take on d4
uh as long as you notice the move and
you start thinking about it you're like
oh okay so i have some
follow-up on e7 um
maybe it's possible that after
um knight f5 knight takes e7 he didn't
see your drook
c4 but i think like c4 i mean rook c4
is kind of just like one of those moves
that's
when you're attacking just comes to you
so
um 94 is definitely worth looking at but
a lot of the players just miss these
kind of moves
because well they're not looking for
tactics uh or they're when like the pawn
is defended by another pawn they
automatically just kind of like ignore
taking it i think it's also something um
subconsciously that's really great so
that point is defending it let's look
for something else
all right so
he went for a3 i
took this a3 and now he did knight d4
i am not entirely sure why he didn't
take knight d4 first to answer your
question better
but i'm assuming that
he just thought that my queen on a5 was
somehow
bothering him more than it should i just
i'm not
entirely sure why he didn't so now
what do you guys think should we go for
bishop g5 or should we take on f1
is there anything different in
this position compared to the previous
one that they were just looking at
i wish i just all my opponents respected
me so much that they never took any
peace of mind that would be great
well in the previous line we didn't
really have time to take queen tanks a2
because everything just happened take
take take so
um well if you think bishop g5 then
maybe give me another move after that
too
so let's say we win for bishop g5
then what if i take king takes g2
i'm gonna take that probably take with
drook
this is still under attack so um
maybe f sexy
maybe rookie 8
yeah i mean i think bishop g5 is doable
but
why not bishop f1 what is the issue with
the ship f1
can you play rook c4 what is the
difference between having my queen on a5
with the pawn on a2 or my queen on a3
is there anything different to your eyes
there is a slight difference
now the queen is not only attacking if
the queen was on a5 the queen was just
like in the a2 pawn
but the queen on a3 is actually going
after
this um a1 bishop
so we could yeah we could try to figure
something out
with that so now
if it's black to move if it's vitamin
white it's going to take and play right
h4
so we got to stop that
and the best way to stop that is with f5
now if you simply take back
i am quite dirt and i can just take here
and take that i am two pieces up
i'm treating mate so
this would be the the way to go
bishop takes g7 after f5 um
i mean i can take that
just can get shades and you still can't
really go anywhere you don't you can add
checks
so f5 would have actually helped the
position quite nicely
i mean after take uh there are still
things to consider
white is still fighting the best that
they can
because now we could drive it like
rookie eight and
then potentially i mean if you still
take i'll take here i
and i'm taking on a1
so
exactly f5 is a must um
so with bishop b2 so now you want to
take their
queen a2 try to exchange the queens and
this
endgame would have given white the best
fighting chance
even though it might not necessarily
look like it i think it doesn't really
matter where to go i would go to d5 just
because
knight on c6 worries me a little what if
i'm gonna drop it so i would definitely
play knight
d5 maybe like go here or start attacking
anyways
so now this end game is a totally
different story
but um at least i'm not getting made it
anymore
right so that is what's different
that is why it would be best if white
had his pawn on a2 instead of having
given it given it up
with a3 there was a question about
now bishop g7 um well bishop g7 i'm i
mean i kind of have to take it
let's only move and what next you can't
really i mean your queen is not getting
there if you play queen f5 you're losing
c1
so it's kind of hard to actually achieve
anything
so giving that um bishop up as well
anyways so in the game after king takes
f1
what do you guys think we should do so
white black to move all of these
c4 threads are still available so you
kind of have to play it accurately
so black to move what should we do
anybody wants to develop anything
retweet anything
play queen a2 to exchange queens
yeah i don't like rookie 8 most of all i
believe i played it as well yeah i mean
i think queen a2 is also doable
but um rookie 8 is
the easiest way to go yes knight f5 now
you play f6
defend your guys rook c5 now what do you
think we should do
white is quite active like if the group
gets to c7 now you might be in some
serious problems
so how do you want to try and um
defend that so if it's white to move i'm
pretty sure where it's going to try with
rook c7
um we do that player fe we penetrate f
e8 and natural k because
your rook on f8 wouldn't didn't really
have anything to do
so if you played the other rook to
e8 then right now your rook would be on
f8 and your rook isn't really attacking
anything he's not
necessarily defending anything
so
yeah i see some rookie xc8s in the chat
yep pro c8 the easiest way
fight for the file stop rook c7
exactly so in the game he went with rook
c4 now what do you think we should do
do you think it's time to try and
exchange queens do you want to take some
wreck
what do you want to do
fragrance you're also correct i thought
i answered your question about
queen f5 i did mention quiz d1 and yes
you're correct squeena c1 would be
defending g5
in the position you are talking about
is knight c2 crazy um
a little bit but let's take a look at it
so what is your idea with knight c2
attacking here and you take you're gonna
take
that guy okay i like that it works c2 i
think you're still gonna do the same
idea
all right i like that so the pro wise
problem
with your knight c2 is the bishop on ha1
right
so um what do we think about
it should be two all right this takes
now that's defended never mind
what do you think about bishop lipsticks
if you take back now white can simply
take this
and your king is becoming a new weakness
growing some weaknesses right
all right so nice it would have been
interesting if there wasn't a bishop of
six
but careful with those little
inaccuracies
i think if c4 is good enough
i stopped repeating myself actually that
was kind of
interesting if that's like that whole
minute of me just repeating myself
i have a nice rhythm to it all right
well thank you
for um staying around this was
i have no idea what's went wrong oh well
all right um
so i was just talking about
i assume we couldn't finish talking
about rook takes c4
so yeah our take c4 will take well the
queen is already on
a2 so yeah so
i um don't really know
what you want to do with your queen but
um we could simply just
take on c4
yeah we can just take on c4 and just
play queen c6 which
oops that would be illegal which is
something that i missed
after knight d6 i couldn't see
um queen c6 when i was thinking about it
so
in this position thinking what drake
takes c4 i thought okay b takes queen
takes my d6
what am i going to do with my clean so
i didn't really see queen c6 with the
idea of queen h1
so i didn't take rook takes c4 which is
kind of sad
i simply played rook d8 because i also
didn't want to take this and then not
take this because well
i i need to defend it and knight d6 is
also coming up
so i made the decision to play d8 which
wasn't accurate
now he got bishop d4 tried to bring them
back to queen and he
started playing some real good moves
like g4
g5 is like everything is just kind of
starting to work out for white
but i have a pretty good move here
so black to move what do you think it's
this good move that i'm talking about
it's quite strange actually um hold on
let me
not um
give you some bad ideas all right so let
me just give you this little thing
um the move that i played i
after not taking rook take c4 i realized
oh my god i could have used that idea so
the move that i played
has something to do with the idea queen
g5 um
is not exactly the move that i'm talking
about so queen b5 would be
um like a follow up move to the move
that i'm talking about
because queen d5 you're not really
threatening anything you can just play
f3
or king g1 or who knows
so something that
we have that like we're gonna keep that
idea a little bit more hidden
so think about queen d5 but in a more
tricky way
like how can you what move can you do
try and provoke opponent into
making a mistake nope
nope
i see the rook e4 but nope yes exactly
knight c6 best move
excellent all right so knight c6 you
can't take because
not queen d5 you're gonna lose your rook
or you're gonna get mated
so i finally saw this idea just like two
moves later than i should have
and after an ic6 um he just played f3
which is good
stopped my queen d5 ideas no more mates
right
but anywho i get queen b5 i'm still
attacking over here attacking that
attacking that
and finally we got rid of this annoying
night and all right so how do you want
to continue now
what we got out of this position is well
black definitely had a vantage because
this is a rook against a knight and a
pawn
but that's not the biggest thing we got
out of this the biggest thing we got out
of this position
is this weak king because this king is
quite weak i get my queen somewhere in
the back rank i get another rook and
well uh scheme is already over
he cannot really attack my king but i
have the chance to attack
white's king exactly queen e5 great
uh he went for knight c6 queen a1 check
he went for king f2 rook d1
as i was just mentioning we want to get
the
back rank by the centralizer queen
we got the queen to the back ring now we
are attacking this poor poor king
um in the game he went for rookie e4
so now how do you guys want to continue
you want to exchange troops
you want to um throw in some checks
what do you want to do
oh hold on hold on no you can't do it
you want just yet
you're gonna get me to hoof careful but
yeah i think rook f1 is good
um i think just playing some rook c8
would have been good enough too just
putting more pressure
i just want to do this in a little while
but i just went to
rook f1 and rook g1
now how do you want to win this
game is almost over just a few more
moves
[Music]
maybe maybe 97 but hold on what do you
guys want to do now
well i mean um
i do like g5 i do like rook c8
i think g5 might have been a little
hasty because g5 just
can goes to f5 and
now this king is actually getting kind
of activated
so let's try with rook c8 first slowly
slowly
no need to rush it um
so after rick c8 my opponent went ahead
and played e3
which was a blunder he should have
played rook e7 rookie 7 would have been
the most accurate
and in this position because i'm also
under attack
i can't really play g5 because the king
just moves and h7 is under attack
but um now i could simply try with
something like
potentially queen c1 try and exchange
the queens
i would lose a7 but i'm going to pick up
b3 soon so it's not the end of the world
but um another thing we could
potentially try
is maybe queen to e1 to
want to try and throw in some checks
there might bring the coin to s4 to
different layer
i think this would also be interesting
so um
anyways he went for e3 but turkey island
would have been the
strongest and i would have actually had
to
spend more time figuring out what to do
so what do you guys think we should do
i found mate in four well actually um he
could have
played other moves but
i think that it wouldn't have really
mattered as much
still pretty
pretty over
so just try and tell me what you think
is the best move
no directory 4 is way too early your g4
you don't have enough pieces you will
just give up your rook for nothing
nope i don't know why do you guys love
rook g4
am i missing something before it doesn't
work just take back
and you throw in the check i'm just
gonna play king back to g3 you don't
have any other pieces to
give me checkmate
nope it's a huge note of rook g4 good
that you're thinking about checks but no
not rook g4
you could try g5 but the key goes to f5
and then you kind of have to figure out
how to check the king from there
um let's see anybody
else want to give it a try
ah you guys miss king can go to g3 oh
boy
um well look it's already on c8
f5 whoa
um i'm not really the biggest fan of f5
i mean i guess this could work because
you can't technically take it
there's queen of six but i it's not the
best it's not the most accurate
i mean just request d4 and now i want to
go the other way
you could try and bring in the queen but
the most accurate is rick c1
so rook c1 the idea is quite simple
you move this queen i'm gonna mate you
g5 if you were to play king f5
now i also have rook c5
uh king e3 k6 is pretty much the only
move and then you're losing this as well
so why didn't you guys talk mention rook
c1
what were you afraid of because rook c1
least of all you're picking up the
knight
so i think c1 should have been the first
thing you
think about yes rook g04 or g5 are worth
considering but
this is uh something that i
recently was assured by my team coach
alejandro because
he was doing streams for the club and i
was watching one of the streams and he
was like
if you can sit down and calculate like
the 10 move line and
um is there amazes they're not made or
you can just
eat material why won't you eat the
material i was like
thank you that's been my chest
philosophy so far so
i did mention that i found a mate
in four but i also said that it's not
forced so the opponent just could have
taken here and it wouldn't have been
made you know
so now but now it's made um
coming up how do you guys think we can
find that mate
let's maintain five at most forced
anybody wants to give a try on how to
find this mate
yeah exactly rick g1 great
so after g1 we just went for king gets
three and how are we gonna mate
we have pretty nice mate coming up
exactly thank you queenly one and you
can't really oops you can't really stop
the screenage format i mean you can try
to give me some checks i guess
but that just feels a little um just
forced it's like i'm not gonna get made
it but i might as well
give it some checks i i wouldn't really
recommend that
but yeah so i think this is um
yeah that's actually how the game went
he played rookie seven
hoping i wouldn't maintain one so he
would make me in one that was kind of
interesting and but i mean i did the
mate
and i ended up winning that tournament i
don't think this was the game that got
me the
the um the title but
it was a very good game and it was a
very interesting
tournament i really liked winning opens
i should win more opens right all right
um i had another game prepared for you
but we got too deep
and questioning so i
not gonna have enough time to go over
that one
if i want to give the
handle to josh riddle for his
end game class all right
well i had a pretty fun um
fun hour with you guys it was pretty fun
i
i missed this game it was a beautiful
game i should play more games like this
right
just like trying to eat pieces and
just end up mating opponent anyways all
right
well this was pretty fun thank you for
joining me
i am going to see you
um either on the twitch channel or
next week right back here have fun with
other instructors alright have a good
week see everybody